From a Breaking Bad movie to a brand new Stephen
King adaptation, there are some great new
Netflix originals landing on the streaming
service next month.
Let's take a look at everything good coming
to Netflix in October 2019.
In the Tall Grass
Nobody needs a reminder of the Stephen King
revival that's happening right now, but fewer
people are aware that King's son, who writes
under the name Joe Hill, is also becoming
a name to know in the horror world.
Hill's 2007 novel Horns was adapted into a
film starring Daniel Radcliffe in 2014, and
his third novel, NOS4A2, was recently adapted
into a series on AMC that looks downright
terrifying.
So what kind of epic premise could they concoct
when they work on a story together?
In the Tall Grass is one of those premises
that only a King could come up with, and only
a King could pull off.
The film, like the story, follows a pregnant
woman and her brother who enter a field of
deadly grass after they hear a child crying
for help.
What follows next is the kind of terror that
takes root and doesn't let go.
You can get your chloro-fill when In the Tall
Grass hits Netflix on October 4th.
Big Mouth: Season 3
For two seasons now, Big Mouth has proven
itself to be one of the raunchiest animated
shows available, following the adventures
of a bunch of school-age children as they
go through puberty.
But underneath the crude humor and poop jokes,
you'll find a lot of heart in this show.
Creators Nick Kroll, Andrew Goldberg, Jennifer
Flackett, and Mark Levin are returning next
month with a brand new season, which you'll
be able to stream on October 4th.
El Camino: A Breaking Bad Movie
As far as series finales go, Breaking Bad
wrapped up its final season with a bow, tying
together nearly every dangling plot thread
in a breathtaking final few episodes and closing
out on Walter White himself sprawled dead
in a meth lab.
So what's left to tell?
Why would creator Vince Gilligan return six
years later to rip off that bow?
One word:
"Jesse."
The last we saw of Jesse, he was driving off
into the night, cackling like a lunatic, finally
freed from those crazy white supremacists.
Where does he go from there?
Remember, this is a guy who recently found
out that his partner watched one of his girlfriends
overdose and did nothing to stop it.
Then he watched someone execute his other
girlfriend, leaving behind a young boy for
whom he cares deeply.
He's going to be carrying a lot of emotions
in this new outing.
Strap in when El Camino: A Breaking Bad Movie
roars onto Netflix on October 11th.
Fractured
The horror continues later this October with
Fractured, a tense psychological thriller
featuring Sam Worthington and Lily Rabe.
Worthington stars as a loving father who goes
on the hunt for his daughter and wife after
they vanish from a hospital emergency room.
The more he searches, the more he begins to
suspect that the hospital itself may have
something to do with the chilling disappearances.
From the sounds of it, Fractured is going
to be chock full of fun, guns, and Sam Worthingtons,
and you can experience the wild ride on October
11th.
Haunted: Season 2
It's the month for all things horror, so it
stands to reason that Netflix would be doubling
down on its scares.
If you missed the first season of Haunted
when it dropped in 2018, here's the basic
premise: People who have had real paranormal
encounters meet with the show's producers
and discuss their experiences, while reenactments
play out along with their stories.
Look for Haunted: Season 2 to scare the living
daylights out of you on October 11th.
The Laundromat
There's a ton of talent packed into The Laundromat,
a biographical film about a shady law firm
located in Panama that spent years helping
some of the world's richest people launder
their money.
Academy Award winners Meryl Streep and Gary
Oldman share screentime with Antonio Banderas
in this off-the-wall comedy directed by Steven
Soderbergh.
After her husband drowns, elderly Ellen Martin,
played by Streep, finds herself inadvertently
on the trail of a widespread insurance fraud
scheme.
Forget about all that real laundry you promised
yourself you'd do, and take a look at The
Laundromat when it opens on October 18.
Living with Yourself
It's a fact: Paul Rudd makes everything better.
From Ant-Man to Celery Man, Rudd brings depth,
charm, and humor to nearly every character
he touches.
This guy would never hurt a fly.
"You're welcome."
In fact, the only thing better than one Rudd
is two Rudds, which is why you should definitely
watch Living With Yourself.
In Living With Yourself, Paul Rudd pulls double
duty as a corporate loser just trying to get
through the day to day grind, and as a better,
funnier, smarter version of himself that emerges
after he undergoes a mysterious spa treatment.
The official trailer teases a show that looks
both hilarious and surprisingly creepy.
Look for it on October 18.
Daybreak
What would you do if you were one of the last
survivors of the apocalypse?
As Netflix sees it, you'd either blindfold
yourself, keep really quiet, team up with
some local high school gangs, take a road
trip with your father in law, get out of the
rain, or just cry a lot.
But what's to say you couldn't enjoy that
apocalypse?
In Daybreak, a nuclear explosion near the
town of Glendale turns the area into a wasteland,
but that won't stop one teen from living life
to the fullest.
The trailer promises a Ferris Bueller-style,
fourth-wall-breaking romp - up to and including
Bueller himself, Matthew Broderick.
Take a look when Daybreak arrives on Netflix
on October 24.
Dolemite Is My Name
Back in the '70s, comedian Rudy Ray Moore
created a fictional persona that he named
Dolemite He went on to make a series of exploitation
films based around that character, and went
down in history.
Who better to play this loud-talking, swaggering
cinematic hero than Eddie Murphy, who steps
into the role of Moore with what critics are
calling "feisty glee."
Wesley Snipes and Keegan-Michael Key costar,
and if you're looking for an absolutely wild
movie night this October, you can stream Dolemite
is My Name on the 25th.
Original stand-up comedy
As we wind down the Netflix originals, we
have to give a shout-out to some of the new
stand-up comedies hitting small screens next
month.
On the first, you'll get front-row seats to
Nikki Glaser: Bangin', an irreverent stand-up
set that sees the comic covering everything
from sex to careers.
On the eighth, look for Deon Cole to take
the stage with Cole Hearted, followed by Jenny
Slate: Stage Fright on the 22nd.
Finally, the month will end on a high note
with a brand new set from Arsenio Hall, Smart
& Classy, on October 29.
That does it for all the fantastic new Netflix
originals to look for in October.
Now let's see what other movies will be worth
staying up for.
New movies
Netflix's upcoming action films are as diverse
as they are explosive.
October first sees the glut of the new arrivals,
with both Charlie's Angels films, Men in Black
II, The Island, and Troy hitting the service
all at once.
You can also rewatch both Bad Boys films in
anticipation of 2020's Bad Boys for Life,
which reunites Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
as the iconic buddy cop duo.
After that, you'll be able to catch the first
Men in Black on October 19th, as well as Master
Z: The Ip Man Legacy on the 23rd.
That's a sweet lineup.
"Edgar what on Earth was that?"
"Sugar."
''Never seen sugar do that."
It wouldn't be October without some new scares,
and Netflix is stepping up to the plate.
The first of the month marks the arrival of
1997's horror satire Scream 2, as well as
2016's Sinister Circle.
You should also keep an eye out for A.M.I.,
an indie screamer about an artificial intelligence
in a girl's phone that convinces her to start
taking lives.
Like the action genre, most of the month's
drama additions land at the opening of the
month.
You'll start seeing some all-time greats in
your browsing options, including Blow, Crash,
Sin City, The Bucket List, and Trainspotting.
We're also getting Ocean's Twelve and Thirteen,
No Reservations, and the Will Smith tearjerker
The Pursuit of Happyness.
Later in the month, don't miss Dark Crimes,
starring Jim Carrey way against type as a
hardboiled detective on the hunt for a cold-blooded
murderer.
And on the 31st, you can't miss Martin Scorsese's
classic Raging Bull.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.